The moment you can compare Allah to
anyone in this world, he's not
God. If someone comes and tells me that
you know almighty God is thousand times
stronger than Arnold Swashnar, you might
have heard the name of Anand Swashnar.
You know he got the title Mr. Universe,
Mr. World supposed to be the strongest
man in the world in the universe. If
someone says Almighty God is thousand
times stronger than Anus Swashinger, the
moment you can compare Allah to anyone
in this world, whether it be Anus
Swashinger, whether it be Dharas Singh,
whether it be King Kong, whether it be a
thousand times, whether it be a million
times, the moment you can compare anyone
to Almighty God, he's not
God. There's nothing like him. This is a
four-line definition of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala given in the glorious Quran
which is the cornerstone of the Quran
which is the cornerstone of Islam and
alhamdulillah Allah says in the Quran in
surah Imran chapter number three verse
number
64 say oh people of the
book come to common terms as between us
and you which is the first term Allah
ill that we worship none but Allah. This
verse of the Quran surah Imran 3 verse
number 64 according to me is the master
key for dawa. When you want to talk to
any
non-Muslim regarding Islam, Allah says
come to common terms as us and you.
Amongst all the common terms, the most
important is
Allahillah that we worship them but
Allah that we associate partner with
him that we erect not among ourselves
lords and patrons other than Allah.
If then they turn back say bear
witness that we are Muslims bowing to
Allah.
This is the master key for dawa. When
you want to talk about Islam to a
non-Muslim, come to common terms as
between us and you. You can start with
anything. You can talk about science.
You can talk about literature. But until
you do not talk about about Allah
subhananaa tala, your dawa is useless.
You may convince him not to have
alcohol, not to have poke, not to cheat.
But if you do not remove the shik from
his life, your dawa is useless. And I've
given a separate talk on this that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
all the major
religions is mentioned in the scripture.
Even though the scriptures have been
changed in the changed form, the true
concept of Allah is there. So when you
get this, you compare with the Quran and
tell your non-Muslim friends to believe
in the true God.
Allah says in the Quran in surah nisa ch
4 verse number 48 and surah nisa ch 4
verse number
that if Allah pleases he may forgive any
sin but he never forgives the sin of
shik of assorted associating partners
with god or joining other gods with god
shik is the biggest sin in Islam
associating partners with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is the biggest sin
in Islam and if a person dies as a
mushri without asking for forgiveness he
will never enter Jenna. Other sins if
Allah please he may forgive but the sin
if you die as a mushri
without coming back to the true path
Allah will never forgive you. Allah says
in the Quran in surah Hajj chapter
number 22 verse number
73 that all those who you
worship all those who you worship
besides Allah if you gather all of them
to create the fly you will not be able
to do it and Allah continues and if the
fly snatches away something you can't
even get it back so all those who you
worship idols and all the other false
god if all of them got together to
create a fly they will not be able to do
it and Allah continues if the fly
snatches away something you can't even
get it back feeble are those who
petition and feeble are those who you
petition therefore shik is the biggest
sin in Islam and
that is the
cornerstone of Islam the first pillar of
Islam